[Música]
hola amigos
para iniciar voy a pedirles que me
ayuden a identificar a unos personajes
que por sus aportaciones han sido
calificados de clase mundial
iniciemos con un inglés un científico
investigador cosmólogo que sus
aportaciones sus descubrimientos el
principal descubrimiento ha sido las
radiaciones de los hoyos negros quiero
saber si ustedes identifican a este
personaje internacional así que ya no
está con nosotros pero que dio mucho a
nuestro universo
steve hoskins exactamente en segundo
lugar les hablaré de otro personaje muy
muy importante que es un músico alemán
compositor que nos ha dejó un legado muy
muy importante con muchas melodías pero
la más importante la más reconocida es
la quinta sinfonía saben a quién me
refiero
a ver a luigi van beethoven y en tercer
lugar quiero mencionarles a una mexicana
universal a una mexicana que ha aportado
grandes obras una una pintora que desde
desde su trinchera supo convertirse en
alguien muy famoso a nivel mundial
reconocen a esta persona
frida kahlo exactamente amigos herida
caló perdón y estos tres estos tres
personajes tan importantes los los
define una característica que aunque sus
aportaciones son grandísimas y
reconocidas hay una característica que
los une y con la cual yo comparto la
discapacidad
ellos tres tuvieron discapacidad
igual que yo y hablando de discapacidad
quiero platicarles sobre mi trabajo en
el centro de rehabilitación y educación
especial
este trabajo es ha sido con niños con
niños con discapacidad y pues deben de
saber que justamente por lo evidente
ha habido muchísima empatía entre entre
estos niños y mi trabajo sin embargo hay
muchos retos dentro de este trabajo
muchos retos que tuve que cumplir muchos
retos que se hacían día a día
me empecé a estudiar empecé a investigar
más para ver qué podíamos aportar para
estos niños y así fue como hice una
especialidad en terapia auditiva verbal
para atender a niños sordos cada día era
un triunfo cada día era una diferencia
en la vida de un niño pero nadie mejor
que yo para saber la diferencia entre
ser rehabilitados no tener la
oportunidad de desarrollo tener
oportunidad de ser a alguien en la
sociedad y ante estas ante estos retos
me vi en la necesidad de decir
y que más y estos niños que más
necesitan yo fui una privilegiada entre
miles ya que pude estudiar soy psicóloga
clínica y terapeuta auditiva verbal en
el centro de rehabilitación pero y ellos
que les esperaba al crecer que les
esperaba hacer
ante una sociedad que día a día debilita
va más la autoestima de los niños con
discapacidad teníamos que hacer algo
teníamos que investigar y tratar de
hacer algo más por estos niños que iba a
ser de ellos cuando fueran adultos qué
oportunidades tenían
entonces nos propusimos hacer una
diferencia buscar cómo hacer que la
sociedad aceptará cada vez más a estos
niños y con con la tendencia de que la
educación es libertad nos propusimos
presentar un proyecto de inclusión
educativa de desarrollo de las personas
con discapacidad a la universidad más
importante del estado
fue aceptado este proyecto
qué triunfo tan grande fue en cuando nos
dimos cuenta que nuestra universidad lo
que hacía era abrir las puertas para
todas las personas sin importar la
condición de discapacidad que se tuviera
todos fueron aceptados todos fueron
admitidos y los siguen siendo sin
embargo qué sucede ahora que ya hay esta
apertura pues esta inquietud si nos dice
que tenemos que seguir subiendo peldaños
pues ahora hay que hacer algo más ahora
tenemos que hacer que los universitarios
que las personas en la comunidad en la
ciudad en todas partes sean cada vez más
incluyentes
esto no es sencillo
es complicadísimo hacer ver y entender
cómo podemos hacer que la gente escuche
lo que significa la inclusión
pero como si ya existen reglas formatos
documentos oficiales de la federación ya
existen leyes internacionales que nos
hablan de inclusión y por qué no se hace
porque no se lleva a cabo
el caso es el desconocimiento
pues tendremos que hacer algo
y en aras de eso me propuse estudiar un
posgrado en la accesibilidad
pero en aquellos años
y escaseaba el dinero tuve que buscar
una beca para estudiar
y presente una propuesta
la cual me iban a dar los resultados en
unos días posteriores sin embargo en
aquel entonces
había algo algo que me inquietaba había
algo que estaba sucediendo en mi cuerpo
con lo que yo no estaba de acuerdo
y lo que hice fue hacerme estudios
especializados e ir a diferentes médicos
y sucedió que el día que yo iba a ir por
el resultado de la propuesta para la
beca team ver a mi teléfono antes de
entrar y era justamente la doctora que
me había hecho una biopsia para saber
qué estaba pasando con mi cuerpo
la doctora me dice
tengo los resultados
necesito que vengas pero no vengas hola
ven con un familiar
imagínense
que les dice eso
la palabra es cáncer
como o sea cómo es posible
no es suficiente tener discapacidad
también cáncer
no sabía qué hacer yo no me acuerdo ni
que le contesté a la doctora solo le
dije que estaría en su consultorio el
día que me estaba pidiendo yo tenía que
entrar a recibir la respuesta que tanto
anhelaba para estudiar un posgrado
no sabía qué hacer
yo sólo recuerdo que colgué y entré a la
oficina para que me dieran el resultado
la persona me dijo fue aceptada tu
propuesta
te vamos a dar los recursos que te
faltan para estudiar tu post grado de
accesibilidad
y
tenemos otras propuestas económicas a
las cuales puedes acceder yo no
escuchaba eso yo no sabía que me estaban
ofreciendo ni que me estaban casi
regalando en mi cabeza sólo había cáncer
cáncer cáncer
pero también estaba
inclusión discapacidad qué va a pasar
con esos niños qué va a pasar con esos
muchachos quién les va a ayudar a seguir
abriendo el camino
había sido tan complicado haber llegado
hasta las puertas de la educación
superior
no nos podíamos quedar ahí sin embargo
seguí en mi cabeza preguntándome qué voy
a hacer
tenía derecho a buscar la sanación
pero y ellos
quien iba a empujar estas puertas de la
sociedad de todos quien podía seguir
tenía que atenderme
pero yo seguía preguntándome que voy a
hacer ya nadie le va a preparar ya no va
a haber quien a quien le interese hacer
algo por la inclusión
no lo sabía llegué a mi casa y como
muchas otras veces que me enfrento a
algunos retos me miré al espejo y solo
me pregunté
qué debo hacer
que debo decidir
no podía dejar de lado mi salud mi vida
pero estaba la disyuntiva acababa de
aprobar el derecho a estudiar posgrado
no sabía qué hacer le pedí a dios que me
ayudara a resolver
esta pregunta de esta inquietud
si hubiera sido algo como elige entre
comprar unas galletas en la tiendita de
la esquina o unas galletas que hace tu
mamá
todos elegiríamos las que nos hace mamá
pero elegir
/ discapacidad y cáncer
era tan difícil
le pedí a dios ayúdame ayúdame entender
ayúdame a resolver
tardé mucho en poderme dormir
pero al día siguiente cuando yo desperté
vi las cosas de otra manera
y me di cuenta que dios me había
respondido
dios me decía
que acaso
no estás batallando por encontrar la
inclusión que acaso no es eso lo que
quieres desarrollar
pues tener cáncer es inclusión
a las personas con discapacidad también
nos da cáncer
ese era un hecho a las personas con
discapacidad nos pasa lo mismo que a
todos ustedes
pero también tenemos los mismos deseos
también tenemos las mismas inquietudes
las personas con discapacidad
buscamos inclusión y en este caso el
cáncer era inclusión
suena duro
pero esa era la realidad
yo me propuse
atenderme atender mi salud atender ese
derecho aunque tenía la sanación
pero también iba a estudiar
todos esos niños que ahora eran adultos
que ahora estaban en la universidad
estaban esperando que alguien como yo
abrir esas puertas tenía que hacerlo
no ha sido fácil
ustedes saben que los tratamientos
oncológicos son muy fuertes son muy
severos
inclusive dañan la salud
pero no deje de ir a trabajar no deje de
estudiar
no fue sencillo hubo tropiezos
pero qué sucedió me gradué dije hay que
darle batalla a esta enfermedad
el diagnóstico
cáncer tipo 4
era algo terrible
mi hermano médico me decía no es posible
esto no puede estar pasando
es muy poco el tiempo que te queda y yo
le dije que te pasa
cuál tú no vas a decidir
yo te voy a estar dando lata muchos años
actualmente ya me gradué
actualmente estoy siguiendo la remisión
que todos los que pasamos por estos
tratamientos oncológicos
debemos tener posteriores de cinco años
de remisión estoy a unos meses de tocar
la campana para decir que no tengo
células cancerígenas en mi cuerpo
pero ahora yo les pregunto a todos
ustedes
si yo
con discapacidad con cáncer he seguido
trabajando por la inclusión ustedes cada
uno de ustedes que han hecho por su
inclusión
por la inclusión de cada uno de ustedes
por el diseño para todos el diseño
universal que ha hecho cada uno de
ustedes por ustedes mismos es tan
sencillo ser incluyente es solamente
pensar en los demás pensar si yo batalló
para cruzar estas escaleras los que
vienen atrás de mí también van a
batallar
si yo no tengo la fuerza suficiente para
abrir un picaporte de una puerta un
picaporte de pomo
qué pasaría con alguien que no tiene
manos
decidan por un picaporte de palanca es
el hombre cualquiera
cualquiera sin manos sin pies
es solo pensar en los demás el diseño
universal es para todos y en todas las
cosas pero si tú
vas a ser incluyente con tu vida tú vas
a hacer que los que están a tu alrededor
sean incluyentes porque tu inclusión los
van a incluir
hagamos algo por los demás les propongo
que cada cada quien piense en las
barreras de cada uno de su casa las
arquitectónicas del trabajo de cualquier
lugar
de las comunicaciones de la salud de la
política de todo
qué tan inclusivos somos algo podemos
hacer por todos los demás los invito a
que seamos incluso incluyentes porque la
inclusión somos todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]